the Joe Rogan experience the only way in
my view and I'm not an expert on this is
discourse mm-hmm and having a platform
where people can argue at each other and
you could stand by and watch and see
things there otherwise if you're
silencing it's it's it's as various as
we talked before and I think any right
minded person would agree is very very
slippery slope I agree did you see the
Ben Shapiro meltdown on BBC I did yeah
yeah that's a good example it's a good
example I don't look he didn't handle it
well he knows he didn't handle it well
and I'd like that you know would like
him a lot I think he's a really nice guy
I like talking to him I don't agree with
him on many things but I really like him
he's a really good guy I think he's a
very smart guy I think he's smart enough
to admit that he [ __ ] up he did he
went on Twitter and I here's the thing I
didn't mean making fun of him it's on my
insta and people are white knighting for
him and I'm like he owned that he played
it wrong yeah yeah he's like yeah I got
got that's to his credit yeah and it
highlights to me more so than anything
the problem with two things one doing a
remote show sure where you from you're
in Los Angeles they're in the UK sure
where you know he was talking to him
like he wasn't there the British guy was
because he wasn't really there right and
then the other part is that short time
format you don't have enough time you
have had time to have a conversation and
just talk but Ben knows this Ben isn't
pro I mean he knows what the BBC is too
but he's also a pro at doing those
things yes to shout talking points at
each other and talk of which and Ben
talk superfast because when I talk super
fast it's really hard to keep up with
him and he sounds smarter than you but
he's very smart
yeah and articulate any talks fast I was
like woo he rose to prominence when he
was on Piers Morgan yeah talking about
guns if you thought that BBC interview
was rude piers at one point just goes
you're real stupid men aren't you like
that's your line way and Ben didn't
storm off he was just like no I just
think when a government becomes
usurpation that's very important for the
citizen had you know and he handled it
good impression we go to the same shul
he handled it amazingly so for him as he
admitted for him to lose his [ __ ] and
also to be like I'm popular and I've
never heard of you yeah that's just
cuz you never heard of someone and I'm
sure he would admit this is of no
relevance to their the validity of what
they're doing